[Música]
hace 8 meses decidí que no decidan por
mí
junto con amigos y amigas vimos que en
todo el mundo millones de pibes y pibas
se estaban movilizando para luchar
contra la crisis climática y ecológica
y vimos que esto podía pasar en
argentina así que decidimos organizar la
primera movilización climática del país
tuvo lugar un viernes 15 de marzo
al principio no creíamos que iban a ir
muchas personas no teníamos muy buenas
expectativas en cuanto a la convocatoria
llegado el día nos terminamos
encontrando con cinco mil manifestantes
en frente de las puertas del congreso y
otros miles manifestándose en distintos
puntos del país a partir de eso dijimos
podría argentina lograr que se declaré
su estado de emergencia climática y
ecológica nos juntamos de vuelta nos
organizamos y presentamos un proyecto de
resolución frente a la cámara de
senadores el miércoles 17 de julio
argentina se convirtió en el primer país
de latinoamérica en declarar su estado
de emergencia climática
[Aplausos]
lo cual igualmente nos marcaba la pauta
de que había un largo camino por
recorrer
y gracias a todos estos logros se me
presentó la oportunidad de participar en
la primera cumbre mundial de jóvenes por
la acción climática convocada por
naciones unidas ahí junto a la activista
greta steinberg pudimos literalmente
decirles a los líderes mundiales lo que
pensábamos en la cara y participando de
reuniones con presidentes muy
importantes y empresarios muy
influyentes me di cuenta que mi
liderazgo no necesariamente tiene que
estar postergado a un futuro que no sé
cómo va a ser me di cuenta que en vez de
ser un líder del futuro
puedo ser un guardián del presente hace
8 meses decidí que no decían por mí
qué pasaría si todos ustedes deciden lo
mismo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]